your job is to put together a team you
trust if you think about everything
you're up against all at once no crack I
[Music]
was there until the very end I'm glad
you got a little time together we got
more than we thought we would
[Music]
this is my job I take lightly I have to
be responsible for everyone
Frances froze help deep space somewhere
I have not a single doubt you will find
sorry boys it's ladies
[Music]
[Applause]
we don't know where they're from
extremely powerful
you're
you're from shield never heard of it hey
everybody is Charlie we got a bunch of
Avengers endgame agents of shield stuff
to talk about so if you guys didn't know
agents of shield season 6 is premiering
this summer they've already shot most of
the season it is like the first Marvel
series that takes place after the events
of Avengers endgame so I'll explain why
they did that and what all this means
and what's going on with the evil dark
version of Coulson because a lot of you
probably picked up on this because they
keep saying that Coulson is dead he is
definitely dead snapped by Thanos and
did not come back so this version of
Coulson is a different Coulson I'll
explain what's going on with that and we
have a better idea of what's going on
with Super Bowl trailers so I'll talk
about that at the end of the video too
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything will do new round of that
Amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a Marvel comment on the video so first
things first big thing about this
trailer is that they're just trying to
let you know that Coulson is dead and
then all surprise evil Coulson shows up
at the end of the trailer Chloe Bennet
and Marvel officially confirmed that are
Coulson was snapped by Thanos during
Avengers infinity war they're standing
on the beach here in Tahiti like they
finally got together to Headey it's a
magical place
then just as they're about to consummate
their relationship that they've been
building for the last five seasons on
the show boom snapped turned to dust and
it just slams to black and that was the
end of agents of shield season 5
happening concurrently with the events
of Avengers infinity war they were
having a giant space battle on agents of
shield on one side of the planet while
Thanos was attacking Wakanda on the
other side of the planet don't ask why
they didn't address any of that on the
TV show or in the movies there were some
references to what was going on in
Wakanda during agents of shield briefly
but they didn't have any official big
crossovers with actors from Avengers
infinity war showing up on agents of
shield we also have new Coulson's stuff
coming up in Captain Marvel but because
that's a prequel it's the 90s version of
Coulson so none of the stuff that they
do during Captain Marvel save for like
some scroll stuff that they could pay
off later in agents of shield episodes
is really going to influence what's
happening during agents of shield season
6 like we might see more alien races
that we meet during Captain Marvel but
we're not even getting these episodes
till after Captain Marvel and Avengers
end game drop in theaters so
be a lot more Easter eggs to talk when
we get full context and actually see
what's going on in the movies but the
way they brought Coulson back on the TV
show because he's still technically dead
he hasn't been brought back yet is a
very Marvel TV type twist so what do the
Marvel TV shows do when they're not
allowed to reference or talk about stuff
that's happening in an upcoming movie
they usually just find a way to explain
around it or they don't address it at
all but because this is such a big thing
like Coulson being dead everyone's
saying that he's dead and then all of a
sudden
evil Coulson shows up at the end of the
trailer of course they have to address
it somehow and it screams one of two big
possibilities based on the ending of
Avengers endgame so number one the
Avengers bring all the snaps people back
but the method that they used puts the
pieces of the universe back together in
a slightly imperfect way like when
everything goes back to normal it
doesn't go back a hundred percent
everything isn't exactly the same so
even though I don't think it's very
likely there Coulson could come back
from the dust and just be a slightly
different version whose alignment is
different because of the way the
Avengers bring everyone back
number two the more logical and more
likely scenario because they're teasing
evil dark Coulson is that this Coulson
is from another universe and it just
somehow crossed the multiverse to get
here so he's not mind wiped or his
reality hasn't been altered post
Avengers endgame issues that he's from a
different universe where shield never
existed or where he was never a part of
it anyone who has ever seen an episode
of Star Trek knows that the minute that
one of your favorite hero characters
starts acting really weird and he seems
like he suddenly turns super evil it's
usually a doppelganger from another
universe yes of course because of the
Captain Marvel movie we should say that
it's totally possible that this evil
Coulson is a scroll but the thing about
Scrolls is is they try to infiltrate so
if he was a scroll he would try to
pretend to be the normal Coulson in this
evil seeming Coulson isn't pretending to
be normal Coulson so that doesn't scream
scroll as much as it screams alternate
universe Coulson the ant-man of the wasp
post-credit scene teased the possibility
of multiverse stuff happening during
avengers endgame so it would make sense
that they would take advantage of that
on the TV shows and they can do dark
Coulson from another
without stepping on the ending of
avengers endgame they don't have to
completely spoil everything because like
they're saying our version of Coulson
the one that was turned to dust is still
dead when the season picks up as far as
anyone knows this Coulson is a
completely different entity so that's
really like the pitch of the season it's
only gonna be 13 episodes they'll all
air during the summer and I don't know
if they've been renewed for more seasons
which is why I think like these other
new powered people that you see in the
trailer are not x-men based characters
they're not mutants because we will be
getting Fox x-men mutants inside the MCU
in the next couple of years but because
they shot these episodes last year and
the Disney deal isn't gonna close till
March if they get a season 7 that's when
you would probably see x-men based
characters showing up on agents of
shield but just remember that all the
twists that you see during this season
probably don't have anything to do with
spoiling the end of Avengers end game
they're just trading on a lot of twists
in tropes that you've seen an infinity
war and during avengers endgame without
necessarily giving everything away we're
talking other alien space races like you
see them open a giant portal with an
alien looking ship in it you see they're
talking about rescuing Fitz that's more
holdover from the end of last season
I'll explain that in a second but for
the most part that should explain the
big shocking twist at the end of that
trailer and it does sound like they're
hyping up dark Coulson as the antagonist
for most of the season if not the
entirety of season 6 because it's only
13 episodes so maybe they'll either try
to turn him good at the end of the
season or they'll get rid of him and
somehow bring our Coulson back from the
ashes because of the actual end of
Avengers end game for those of you that
do actually watch agents of shield and
want to know about the other stuff
that's going on in the trailer Mack is
now director he's got this Coulson
hologram that's teaching him all these
things so that's how they keep Clark
Gregg in all the scenes because if
Coulson is dead you have to find a way
to keep Clark Gregg on the show so
that's why they do dark Coulson that's
why they do Holograms so even though
Clark Gregg was shooting Captain Marvel
Coulson's stuff for that movie he's
still going to be a big part of agents
of shield season 6 they talked about
finding Fitz he's still stuck in outer
space remember he froze himself last
season in this elaborate time-travel
plot so that he could wake up in the
future and help his friends so he's
stuck on this spacecraft that's
nearby there was an evil alliance led by
the Cree that were trying to mine earth
for all of its gravitonium last season
they're still around but they killed
most of the leaders of that including
the Cree one so we're gonna get a whole
bunch of Cree during the Captain Marvel
movie I don't know how big they're gonna
be during agents of shield season 6 the
people that Daisy's fighting on the
spaceship here seem like they're
humanoid but they also seem like they
have powers so either they're in humans
that were sold off during the course of
season five that are being used by other
evil people or they're pink-skinned Kree
or they're gonna be another alien race
but they just seem like the main
antagonists when the season picks up but
they don't really give you any kind of
overarching plot aside from finding fits
in the mystery of dark Coulson like
there's no like singular goal like we
have to obtain a certain thing there's
no MacGuffin that they give you just the
idea that most of season 6 seems like
it's still gonna take place in outer
space which allows them to sort of
sidestep Avengers endgame and not have
to give away any big spoilers because
I'm pretty sure that the producers have
no idea how Avengers endgame is actually
going to end because most of the actors
who are starring in Avengers endgame
like Mark Ruffalo or a war machine here
they're doing reshoots right now this
person actually caught them on set
they're still doing reshoots for that
movie so the actual end could still
change between now and April when we
actually watch it but if they have no
idea how the movie ends then the people
that make Marvel TV shows who have
nothing to do with the movies also
probably have no idea how it's going to
end so when you're thinking about agents
of shield theories just take that into
account assume that they had to plan
around that so when you're thinking
about dark Coulson and all these are the
big twists and other alien races that
they could use just try to take into
account some of the theories about how
Avengers endgame ends and the Avengers
fix things because remember the other
big thing that's happening after
avengers endgame this summer is
spider-man far from home so I know
everybody saw has tons of questions
about the timeline because spider-man
got snapped and suddenly he's back in
his acting like everything seems normal
even though he kind of wants a vacation
like you just don't see the weight of
all those deaths hanging on him in that
trailer I think they did that on purpose
there will probably be moments during
the movie or at least at the beginning
of the movie where they address all the
stuff that happened like his summer
retreat with the Avengers where they
went to outer
he died and then came back to life most
of the main Avengers will probably
remember just because it's so important
for their character growth like if they
don't remember anything that happened
then how could their characters possibly
grow but for everybody wondering about
what's going on with Marvel trailers
during the Superbowl
Mark Ruffalo posted this to his Twitter
account this morning has anyone seen the
Avengers
[Music]
somebody's guys I can see your face you
know when I do this you go so based on
that it just seems like he is implying
that they're ramping up for own vengers
endgame Super Bowl trailer so of course
I'll do a video for it we'll probably
get some more information about other
trailers in the next couple of days so
I'll just keep updating people as I post
videos click here to learn about all the
secret sinister six stuff going on in
the spider-man far from home trailer and
click here to rewatch that birds-of-prey
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome see you guys
tonight
[Music]